just pens down for a minute I just work
with the boys you see what I just did
don't do that you have been asked to
prove this right you've been asked to
prove it show that it is true in other
words you don't know that it's true yet
you're supposed to end there you can't
start there you can't begin with this as
your first line okay if you do want to
write down the questions it's helpful to
have it in front of you rather than your
back and forth my kind of thing which I
like to do then at the front gate and I
am having to write that in aa three day
which is pretty well recognized acting
for required to prove okay in other
words what I'm saying I'm not saying
it's true I don't know that yet but
that's where I'm headed okay so here's
what I require proof how am I going to
go about doing it I can't certainly you
can see all look I recognized some stuff
in fact a lot of this will come down to
at the beginning knowing these things
and sign to muck about with them and use
them okay it's not before I even get to
that and pedal back a little bit
attempting to write it down and touch of
a dip us what I said you can't do the
first thing you're going to do is start
with one side of the equation and then
work with that until you get to the
other side now I've chosen to start with
the left hand side you can start with
the rice if you like in some examples
I'm going to show you I will can anyone
suggest to me why might we want to start
on the left rather than the right in the
original yeah because you're on your
brain have been wired for the last time
of years to simplify things so take
something that's messy and work with
until it looks simpler you can do it in
the opposite direction if you can start
with something simple and make up
messages but it doesn't really gel with
the way our brains are sort of wire to
work it's a lot more difficult so I
suggest you start with what was messy
and then work from there okay so I'm
going to write down the left-hand side I
love you to do the same right and it is
don't do any manipulation to it just yet
now what you want to do is keep one eye
on what you're working on and your other
eye on where you're going okay so think
back to when we're doing finance era and
you got asked to prove you know this you
know this see this see this like this
see that equals some other being with
factorials inner okay you've got to know
where you're heading right and just
simplifying blame unity I want to get a
sine theta on a numerator and a cod
speed up on this denominator okay so
what can I do [ __ ] now I'd like to take
a difference in the other arm expert
minus one equals 10t of it then
okay so you can see over here I've
pointed out if you take the plastic
identity in the original ones primary
one and you massage it a little bit then
you get all these sorters like you know
parallel universe versions of the
pythagoreanism and this exact one fits
into shield right so I can write instead
of copied on our sorry instead of six
four three two one I can write top
bigger times 10 squared are you happy
with just about any metal just messing
it okay now I wonder if you can see now
how this is going to pan out right this
is a proof this is a proof so even if
you can see it you're like oh cool
BAM we're going to write down the answer
we already know what the answer is going
to be so the burden is on you to show
why it is what it is so here's what I
would do to make it really obvious
I would convert cut into Cod on time
I actually know one on hands down to
this it's just in simple right I've got
the reciprocal death I've got hands as a
two in there and now that's that's
pretty obvious right you agreeing like
everyone can see that
whereas not everyone will recognize that
so that's where I was trying to go
equals
the right hand side I'm finished okay
so I started with a messaging then I
went to the simple fear and I don't
that's it now please make sure you run
one phone and then move to the other
lots of people they look at this and
then they just are worthless
they're like oh I'll multiply both sides
by column and then always route this to
the other side and it just becomes a dog
[ __ ] okay moves from left to right or
right to left engine up which slightly
starting with let's say bye sometimes it
just slapping the bed obviously shine
you should begin with I will come in
later lessons too when it's not so
obvious but when out but just you were
using the identity recognizing lesbian
sightings cruelly disaster it got two
things I can combine them and hopefully
this is where I end up okay now the true
fraction so what is the missing pieces
get a common denominator and then you
can combine them into one you should
know that's where you're headed please
look over the right hand side there's
one object in so clearly it's true I'm
going to have to melt again what is the
common denominator that will work one
minus sine squared theta
do you notice that Chris look if I
multiplied it by one minus sine beta
multiply this by 1 plus idea you've got
different two squares yes so I'm just
going to do that now
I've got one time zero
okay what do you think what do you think
now let me say this again what being
extension is can do number one recognize
what you can do with this being you can
see it's actually sort of luring the
line between algebra and trigonometry
stand up different squares being that's
analogous in well it can work in
trigonometry - and because you've got
the Pythagorean identity which all that
squares you can see that sample okay I'm
not really my efficient your religion
recognize me and manipulate I also want
to especially to communicate clearly so
see what happens from here - she are I
didn't do that at the same time is
converting this denominator I just want
to make it really obvious what each step
is about I should be able to stream from
your working oh okay
from this lines of this line he
understands how to combine fractions
from this lines of this line is use the
Pythagorean identity from this line to
this line she knows what the reciprocal
gods and admission